all righty then it is time for drew's
news your hand-picked bushel of juicy
good news berries numb with me at the
desk is my little boysenberry rossy ross
map yes
hi everybody
oh yellow drew
well i'm excited for our first story
rossi because someone is
sort of preaching something that i
definitely feel like i've said and
people get all you know
higgledy-piggledy about it
so i'm kind of excited i feel like i
have like a sister out in the universe i
know and i'm not a big fan of this you
know that well we disagree we'll see
what the people think that's true all
right for anyone who loved the flight
attendant did anyone love the flight
attendant i'm a fan of that so good love
heart love well it's back on hbo max and
kaylee cuoco is back for more
nail-biting drama but when it comes to
marriage this flight attendant is cool
in her jets people reports kaylie just
divorced from carl cooke her second
husband and she says quote i will never
get married again
she said she'd love a long-term partner
but marriage is absolutely not happening
and she said that people could quote her
and put that right on the cover
yeah yes and good for her if that's what
she wants
i don't like it and i'll tell you why i
have have you ever been in a position
where you ate like a whole pizza to
yourself and you're like oh my god i'm
never eating pizza again
and then you know a day comes around
when you're like you know what sounds
good is some pizza and i'm just telling
you you may be saying now drew i never
want to get married again but what about
one day 30 years from now you meet
somebody who's your person and it's
important to them
right
do you think maybe then you change your
mind no
no
no absolutely not what if they fed you
pizza if we brought it back around to
that would you
if you wrapped anything up in pizza i
feel like i'd be in i i just i think
what she's trying to say is like it's
not that you're not a romantic anymore
or that you judge other people or you
don't want to be at their weddings or
everybody could get married around you
it's like almost like you realize like
you're not good at this thing and you
don't want to try it anymore
yeah i can respect that i can i just
want there to be a little crack in the
window where you're like can change your
mind is that too much to ask that you
could change your mind
some people rock it like elizabeth
taylor and like you know jlo and ben
like people have you know marriages they
get back together or you know they they
do it and they just make it look so cool
yeah i don't feel like i'm like that guy
okay
i feel like it's like oh god if you
break up you break up it's it's not the
world's biggest deal but a divorce just
feels like such a oh it's i don't know i
don't think i can
take it again i got i i get that and i
have your back and i just want to say in
30 years if you text me oh my god russ
i'm getting married i won't say i told
you so
okay i won't
i won't even bring it up
i won't show you this clip i won't say a
word you know i hope
that one day i eat my own words and you
play this clip and you rub my nose
i do i hope that i'm wrong did you hear
that she said i do did you hear that
she said it
[Applause]
ah you're just practicing
i am and maybe
i am
stay tuned everybody stay tuned see that
took a turn all right well now there's
an exciting halloween movie brewing and
it might be a new instant classic
jezebel reports filming just wrapped on
a movie called spirit halloween it's a
spooky movie set inside one of those
spirit halloween stores you know that
they just like pop up so you're like
when that get here well now it stars the
incredible christopher lloyd who we love
oh man christopher lloyd back to the
future taxing the best
he's in it he's so great at playing
creepy plus there's a cast of young
middle schoolers who dare each other to
spend a night locked inside a spirit
halloween and they're saying it's
inspired by classics like the goonies
and gremlins
and those spirit halloween i mean
they're so great except i always end up
going in on like october 30th at 8 pm
and there's nothing scarier than that
scene in a spirit house and it's in like
a weird old empty sears they just turned
into a spirit halloween story would you
you want to watch this and would you
spend a night in one i mean there's no
doubt i'm going to be seeing this movie
because this is my daughter frankie's
fantasy come to life you saw her
birthday invitation yeah
it's like a ghost and she was like i you
know won a a bloody death-themed
birthday party and i was like okay i
don't know how to phrase that on an
invitation
that is not going to get me outed in the
parent community um so she's going to be
all over this yeah yeah you want to go
see this movie when it comes out
together
can i bring frankie of course hello
i'll be scared frankie can comfort me
yeah exactly she's not scared by
anything
[Music]